bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france donc jusqu'à
l'heure le l'exécutif et tv tissant à à
passer à l'obligation du télétravail bon
c'est une mesure qui a été annoncé pour
au moins trois jours par semaine
votre avis là-dessus
le télétravail est effectivement une
option intéressante pour dans le cadre
de la lutte contre contre la pandémie
donc oui mais en réalité je me réjouis
je je je suis conduire très interrogatif
sur la cohérence de l'ensemble au
gaucher de l'ensemble de ces mesures on
a vraiment l'impression d'un
gouvernement qui navigue à vue je le
rappelle vous l'avez mis des reportages
que le gouvernement est en train de
sonder la possibilité de réduire la
durée d'isolement pour les quatre ça
c'est totalement contradictoire avec
tout ce que vous voulez dénoncer comme
mesure on a effectivement un
gouvernement qui semble un petit peu
le le doigt comment il savait en train
de souder où se situe le vent un peu
comme un cavalier sans tête et
effectivement il ya des
dysfonctionnements majeurs dont l'une
contre la réunion ne comprend pas
continuent à supprimer des lui dédie à
ne pas renforcer des moyens pour
l'hôpital public on ne comprend pas les
efforts plus puch plus importante
renforcée dans le sens du traçage des
moyens pas restée massivement qu'en
est-il de l'école alors écoutez circulez
ya rien à voir pouvait bien à l'école
alors qu on sait qu effectivement une
population jeune et des enfants font
bien ciblés par les variants beat von
bon bah voilà yahia ou qu'un protocole
sanitaire renforcée à l'école on
comprend on comprend que le gouvernement
à son temps à s'établir à se dédire mais
mais par contre y'a t'il politique
cohérente non car on allait à s'ouvrir
on peut plus on peut plus être debout
dans les bars c'est à dire visiblement
le on buzze de la stratégie c'est boire
sa terrasse ici quand même ça laisse
songeur sur l'aspect obligatoire du
télétravail et qu'est ce que vous dit
souvenez vous il ya des discussions
aujourd'hui entre les partenaires
sociaux et la ministre du travail et les
avait deux bornes on a toujours été très
clair sur le télétravail je voulais dire
l'instant on a toujours été très clair
le télétravail quand il est possible
effectivement est une mesure
intéressante on rappelle que pour autant
d'ailleurs la cgt soit justement pouvoir
cadrer le télétravail que ce soit pas
simplement du travail à la maison en
laissant effectivement finalement les
patrons organisé ça comme il le souhaite
que ça puisse accompagner vu que ça a
été largement généralisée et pendant un
temps et que là on n'y reviendrai que ce
soit effectivement assorties de
dispositions contraignantes pour les
employeurs et là dessus eh bien on n'est
pas souhaitée par le gouvernement voilà
donc ça c'est ses bourreaux dans
effectivement c'est une option
intéressante les jolies ces contraintes
est favorable à l'obligation du
télétravail
on est favorable à ceux effectivement
cette mesure elles soient effectivement
proposé comme piste prioritaire par je
viens de vous le dire je suis clair dans
ce que je dis je pense nous on a un
problème avec le fait que le cadrage du
télétravail ne soient pas assorties de
dispositions contraignantes pour les
employeurs que ce ça ça ne s'improvise
pas on une forme de flou artistique
autour d'un travail à la maison il ya
des droits donc du travail ça peut pas
être effectivement sur le dos des
sanctions contraignantes pour
l'employeur mais calme c'est à dire que
écueil est par exemple dans le cadre
d'un accord national interprofessionnel
des dispositions sur par exemple style
en est de 2 3 des chèques restaurant ce
qu'il en est de 2,2 des droits cas le
salarié dans l'entreprise et que ça ne
se solde pas par un mois dix ans pour
les salariés voyez comme elisabeth
bornes évoque des contrôles qui vont
s'intensifier notamment au niveau du du
télétravail à la rentrée qui est visé
selon vous sa jeu je suis pas dans le
secret des dieux c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que ce matin il y avait effectivement
des discussions qui se passe où la cgt
est représenté et ou de mes camarades
auront tous les éléments entre les mains
voilà donc la moi là dessus sur les
annonces précises et les propositions
concrètes que nous n'avons pas que c'est
la réunion se passe en ce moment eh bien
je vais tout à fait confiance à mes
camarades pour pouvoir effectivement
juger sur pièce ce qu'il errait ce qui
leur est proposé dès ce que je tiens à
dire c'est que ces mesures sont
contradictoires avec une autre piste que
le gouvernement cherche effectivement à
explorer à savoir baisser voire
éventuellement
supprimer la durée la durée d'isolement
des cas contacts ça a effectivement
c'est totalement contradictoire avec
avec jupe avec justement cette mesure
sur le télétravail est donc on en
revient à ce que je vous disais le
manque de cohérence la profitation et
les mesures gadgets merci beaucoup pour
cette réaction baja mamar porte-parole
la cgt valdemar merci à vous